SHE HASN'T SEEN IN SO LONG ♪
♪ IT'S MY BOYFRIEND'S FRIEND'S
BIRTHDAY AND I WAS FREE ♪
♪ WILL I KNOW PEOPLE THERE HE
SAID YOU'LL KNOW ME ♪
♪ I SAID I DON'T LOVE STRANGERS
BUT I DO LIKE TO DRINK ♪
♪ EVERYBODY THIS IS PHIL HEY I'M
FRIENDS WITH ALEXIS ♪
♪ THIS IS MY SISTER I FLEW IN
FROM TEXAS ♪
♪ I FINALLY BROUGHT MY
GIRLFRIEND THAT'S ME I'M
HEATHER ♪
♪ WHERE DID YOU FEET WE ALL GREW
UP TOGETHER ♪
♪ THEY LEAVE US AT THE TABLE AND
THEY GO TO A SHOP THEY ASK US
SAVE OUR SEATS ♪
♪ WE SAY SURE WHY NOT ♪
♪ NOW WE'RE THREE STRANGERS THAT
ARE FRIENDS ♪
♪ OH-OH-OH OH-OH-OH ♪
♪ WE GOT CAUGHT AND WE DON'T
KNOW EACH OTHER ♪
♪ WE GOT CAUGHT SO WE ALL HAVE
TO SUFFER ♪
♪ WE ALL WANT TO LEAVE BUT IT'S
ONLY 8:00 ♪
♪ WE GOT CAUGHT ♪
♪ WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH THROUGH I
ASK WHERE ARE Y'ALL FROM ♪
♪ AND I COULDN'T THINK OF A
SINGLE OTHER QUESTION ♪
♪ SO I ALSO ASKED WHERE ARE
Y'ALL FROM ♪
♪ WE COVERED THAT.
>> ANYBODY HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION?
>> OKAY, SO WHAT'S Y'ALL'S
TRAUMA?
♪ I MADE MY ESCAPE AND SAY I'M
GOING TO THE BEDROOM ♪
♪ AND THIS CRANKY BITCH SAYS
I'LL GO WITH YOU ♪
>> NO, YOU WON'T.
>> IS SHE LEAVING?
♪ WE'RE WAITING AT THE BAR BUT
NO ONE'S COMING BY ♪
♪ AND IF THERE'S ONE SECOND OF
SILENCE THEN WE'LL BOTH DIE ♪
♪
♪ I REACH INTO THE DEPTHS OF
WHAT I KNOW AND I SAY, DID YOU
KNOW THERE'S ONLY BEEN 25 DEATHS
AT DISNEYLAND SINCE 1955 ♪
♪ AND SHE SAID ONLY?
♪
♪ WHAT NEIGHBORHOOD IS YOUR
APARTMENT IN, SHE SAYS BROOKLYN,
I SAY WHEREABOUTS THIS
BROOKLYN ♪
♪ AND SHE SAYS OH THE SAFE PART
WHICH WAS SHOCKING SO I PANICKED
AND ALL I COULD SAY WAS ♪
OH, GOOD.
I LOVE SAFE PARKS.
>> NO, I SAID THE SOUTH PART.
>> NO!
♪ WE GOT CAUGHT ♪
♪ YOUR MUTUAL WAS GONE YOUR
MUTUAL WAS MISSING ♪
♪ YOU'RE WONDERING WHY YOUR
FRIENDS ARE REMINISCING ♪
♪ WHERE ARE OUR FRIENDS WHERE
HAVE THEY GONE WHY WOULD THEY
LEAVE US ALONE ♪
♪ YOU'RE ALL OUT OF TOPICS AND
THE CONVERSATION'S LAZY ♪
♪ YOU JUST KEEP ON SAYING
THEY'RE CRAZY THEY'RE CRAZY ♪
♪ THEY'RE CRAZY NO WAY THEY'RE
CRAZY OH CRAZY ♪
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
>> SO CRAZY.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU, IT'S
GETTING LATE.
>> 8:05?
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE
ANYMORE!
♪ WE GOT CAUGHT ♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]